alleanza contro il rosso ci stava bene
va bene
mousse in brasile io non faccio più
dentro sono pigro basta
devi morire ma le ho sbagliato scusa tu
sei sta roba
non lo so come di le mappe nuova perché
storia di uno jared usa è aiuto
notificata non mai viste strohmaier non
mi sparano volevate cos'è a sono io sono
io e bossi ma veramente non ci credo
sono un bossolo che figata video
battermi quanto è diventato figo questo
gioco new face à ea fasi per un tipo
dark souls mi state pure battendo come
aia non potete nulla esseri schifosi non
potete nulla contro di me
ma cos'è sta roba
aia bounce sono morto ci sono riuscito e
siete riusciti a battermi come è stata
navigati incredibile sta roba armi
grigie zenit sono sempre io sempre io
che mi faccio il cu li stavolta prima
non sapevo come giocare così come non
morire mai però come detto sei morto ed
era quello che mi interessava pezzo
salve signor rosso cos'è mamma mia che
bella gara ho mai power led è stato
bellissimo e geniale sta roba dei boss
allora chiarimento ma sono morto al sono
morto prima ora lasciamo rilasci grazie
va dai fucili e un giro mamma mia quanto
difficile come avete fatto prima a
battermi impossibile sacri scarso per i
mazzieri ammazzati
cene combatterlo pure da solo a mezzo
video da voi dai e mezza vita ha detto
niente certo ho fatto io è figura era un
macello macello no no no no ci racconta
ciao a tutti io no sono vivo sono bordo
solo dio perdona ma è scemo e scemo e
drogato
no io penso sempre di essere quello con
la corale no no no pietro pietro pietro
lui lui lui bravo bravo bravo bravo
ce lo colpisce meglio fater prendetela
tra di voi e che io non c'entro niente
una lancia di nuovo cantone macchiato
aspetta la lancia finissima varenne ai a
porcia averci passato era gigante e si
sono visti subito i giocatori stavano
vai vai e ti chiamo picchiamo casa my
heart e ucciso a te come mi sto
ritagliando c'è il giallo è sì
ma come pretesto l'arma destra non c'è
bisogno di roma sono massacrati
fichissimi scherzavo aiutarlo come
sembrate non sono capace pietro
ahi ahi ahi che male ciao nostro campo e
si molla ecco l'ho mollata
no ho fatto una cosa bellissima ma un
fattore caldo bellissima cep allemande
così vaghe rosso stupido maledizione che
ne armi in rosso dalla serie b tonchi va
fatta perfetto però se non mi spari a me
basta ma puoi essere te guerra come sei
morto poi cosa coro ma la era spesso la
squadra colla spara kakà una mente mi ha
fatto un bene non c'avevo prima a ya no
no no perché ho peccato the air force
raf sono che olivo sono attaccato alla
spezia casa grazie sono anche la rimonta
salverò salve no non farlo non farlo non
farlo mai diceva se non sono fatto per
non ci credo non sono un fatto vincere
wow
come mai neanche matrix la vittoria del
genere una lancia di nuovo già morto io
male hanno aggiunto adesso stai armi non
c'erano prima
no c'erano prima ma sicuro la lanciano
le orme di steno vorrei contenta li
ingloba meno male che stupido minore che
subito ai non ho fatto mia azione sono
morti da soli o ecco la quale arma vella
no
ma cos'è ma su geniali se armi ma non
avevo mai tornata neanche mezza così
[ __ ] prima alle no cosa diavolo e questa
roba
se riusciamo a non volevo giuro non
volevo creare un buco nero ma veramente
ma quanto fibra è diventato assaggiarlo
sparato io sono morto l'inglesissimo
come se lo sapeva fosse un buco nero ma
chi lo farò
no quella non è non è l'arma più [ __ ]
del gioco quella no la scuola serpente
figo beh il buco nero spara serventi nel
buco nero è una gara e mi sa di sì mi sa
che se anche vincendo occhio che non
vince pietro non restate giorno non ma
perché non volevo beccarti non sono
anche doveri ma avanti ma come ha fatto
il celebre dai vai questa prima questa
buona ma che viene da rilassarmi ogni
volta per terra fare tipo da 2.000 a ya
poiché poi quella cristiana ha fatto
alla riscossa occhio occhio la regolare
ma come fa sparare così che non ha visto
linea vuoi non toccare me che problemi
hai rotto le balle pietro basta ma se
trova un armata marzo ma sono con tempi
come hai fatto a uccidano tu mi vieni
qua come hai fatto ci dà tutto spiega mi
non mi sono neanche ma sono stato fermo
un arma qua grazie grazie mille molto
gentile
ciao rosso tutto bene e molto subito
ragazzi vi in corno bossi bossi
incornati amico mio no vieni qui vieni
qua no ti sei cagata se no sei
incastrato lancia come possibile con che
fisica
amo questo gioco nokia rosso mi uccide
speriamo chiamassi voi prima di me ma
perchè conosceva come scusa ai ai
sacchetti la vita è bella
io l'hanno fatto assolutamente nulla
sono guardati morire prove ma perché
erano sta sempre più vicino alle cose
alleanza contro rosso ci stava bene va
bene
mussini
apcom estivo domani è incredibile non
c'è stata bellissima ma è proprio
ufficio proprio no mi stanno
schiacciando le casse che a gare
volutamente no ma se noi sapete no il
successo di lager
no sono vivo arca lacca aiuto aiuto mi
sapete di portare armi non vale che
vittoria incredibile live ti lascio
l'onore di perché voglio farti culetto
[Musica]
giusto solo perché voglio farti il culo
pietro home page di pancia reato così
mentali mazza no no non è vero non è
vero non è vero ma non è vero mai nella
vita
ma quanto sei venduto quanto figo sto
gioco cosa vedendo cosa è successo hai
vinto tu lo hai vinto tu hai fatto una
mossa che non ho capito previsto to back
in quanto vivo beh il rosso è partito
bene visto livello no no no non mi tocca
grazie di tre io non so colonna di avere
ragazzi questa è la sti fight spero vi
sia piaciuto abbiamo gradito di brutto
la novità dei boss quindi cerchiamo in
un prossimo video ragazzi non so che
siete in cui ci vediamo a cosa vedo io
[Musica]